Our people are scattered like stars in the
galaxy what are we what do we stand for
being a Mandalorian is not just
learning about how to fight
you also have to know how to navigate the Galaxy
that way you'll never be lost
so that I may be forgiven for my transgressions
this is the way
there's something dangerous
happening out there and by
the time it becomes big enough
for you to act it'll be too late
hang on kid
this is the way
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is the way
there's a brand new Mandalorian season 3 trailer
to break down there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs and references so if you're brand new to the
channel I'll be doing videos for all the episodes
just like I did for season one and season two be
sure to subscribe to get them we'll just start at
the beginning of the trailer footage and work our
way through shot by shot talking about Easter eggs
and WTF moments some of it is repeated footage
from the previous trailer with new dialogue and
some of it's just like completely brand new scenes
it starts on that same foreign plant that we saw
in the earlier trailer with Mando in the group of
other mandalorians talking about what happened
to the mandalorians after the Great Purge they
scattered to the sky like stars all the survivors
hiding in different planets in the outer rim and
during his voice over dialogue he's talking about
what it means to be a Mandalorian because John
Favreau and Dave floony said that that's what
season three is all about it's all about the
mandalorians culture and one of the cool things
here is that it sounds like he's almost talking
to grogu about what it means to be a Mandalorian
because for a long time we've had this theory that
the title of the Mandalorian series isn't just
about Mando it's also about grogu and grogu will
eventually become a Mandalorian because being a
Mandalorian isn't so much about being born into
their race it's about adopting their Creed
me that grogu could theoretically become a
Mandalorian how do you say this is the way in
Yoda speech the way this is which Dave filoni
has since clarified about how Yoda speaks he said
that that backwards way of speaking is just unique
to Yoda and he did it to honor his Jedi Master
who spoke that same way all the other members of
his race like yaddle for instance speak normally
do who step to me whatever your crimes are help
me now so that means when grogu eventually does
speak words he'll speak normally his whole speech
about being a Mandalorian not being about just
how to fight is about how learning to survive
in the wilderness is meant to set up the end tag
scene with grogu taking down the alien that tries
to kill him inside the cave because just like
Yoda would say judge him by his size would you
he's super powerful in the force he goes back to
Navarro they have the scene with grief karg again
we saw that in the previous trailer they have all
the salacious crumbs hiding in the tree there he's
basically become the Magister of this city now
like he's in charge of the city he's got the 3PO
Droid with him he speaks with the armorer to talk
about how he's going back to the planet Mandalore
to reclaim his honor as she told him he needed
to do it seems like she's on that same rocky
planet with all these other mandalorians this
is the planet Mandalore this is their giant Dome
City Post Purge like after it was blown up by the
Empire years ago we saw this all during the Clone
Wars like we've been inside the city many times
when it wasn't blown up when it was still intact
we get a May the force be with you from Peli motto
more of grogu pressing buttons and here is Captain
Carson tiva on Coruscant if it wasn't clear that
going back to Coruscant during season three and we
see doctor purging flying it seems kind of like
a scene out of attack of the Clones or Revenge
of the Sith like you would have seen during the
prequels with him just flying through the space
Lanes there we also just saw a scene like this
during the Andor series the intercut other footage
with Mando and grogu talking to Boca tan who seems
like she's in a version of the hallway with a
throne of Mandalore they might actually say that
this is the throne roof amandalore but the only
changes is that during the Clone Wars Episodes the
throne room itself looked very different so this
could just be a reinterpretation of that or just
a different part of the throne room but I think
this chair is meant to be the actual Throne of
Mandalore or at least as bokeh tan thinks of it
it might just be the Throne of Mandalore but on
a different planet like they recreated it after
they scattered to the Galaxy but the whole idea is
that Mando has the darksaber and that's meant to
be the right to rule the sign line of rulership
so technically the Throne of Mandalore should
belong to him by rights but bocatan believes
that it's hers and she has to find a way to get
the darksaber from him but she has to win it the
right way or else her people won't follow her so
it seems like right now they just have a tenuous
Alliance like she's not super happy about the
situation but she doesn't absolutely hate Mando
so she's just gonna use him however she thinks
she can to bring her people together so that they
can retake the planet Mandalore because that's
what she ultimately wants is to retake the planet
when they talk about it being too late these just
seem like the caves beneath Mandalore where he's
finding these helmets just the ruins of previous
battles this seems like another order 66 flashback
another grogu flashback we got a little bit during
the book of Boba Fett so it just sounds like he's
going to be remembering more things from Order
66 about how he was rescued and sent into hiding
maybe Hayden Christensen did another Cameo scene
as Anakin Skywalker I didn't hear that there was
going to be one I do think that we're gonna get
some flashbacks with him during the Ahsoka series
though more about Ahsoka in a second because those
episodes will also be coming later this year so
we'll get another trailer for that before too
long we go back to present day and there are
a bunch of Thai Advanced chasing after Mando
inside his ship been a little while since we've
seen some Tai Advanced I'm not sure where he is
where he's in this room with all these Droids but
remember the joke that's the whole thing is that
Mando hated droids up to about season two he's
kind of backed off that just a little bit like
he doesn't hate them quite as much heading into
season three so maybe this scene just has some
jokes about that droids we don't serve their kind
here but then Mando steps into this other bar and
it's nothing but droids we only serve droids in
this bar here there's a whole bunch of R2 units
in here there's some battle droids there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs for Droids from across the
Star Wars Canon the group of blue mandalorians
might be part of bocatan's night owls group but
they also might be part of the armorers group
which is like a completely separate group of
mandalorians because the heavy infantryman is
here and we know that he's team armorer and we
know that the armor absolutely hates Boca tan
so it's meant to be like a completely separate
faction of mandalorians I cannot wait to see if
they are going to fight bocatan versus the armor
they have a scene with a bunch of Babu Fricks
Rays then they end with the tag scene of grogu
taking down this giant animal with the force
the fact that he takes it down with the force
with the voiceover dialogue this is the way just
supports the idea that eventually groku is going
to actually become a real Mandalorian like he will
take the actual Creed at some point and consider
himself a Mandalorian like Mando the other big
thing that they don't show in the trailer here is
Grand Admiral thrawn and there have been rumors
about him being a much bigger character during
the Ahsoka Series so I do think there'll be some
sort of teaser at the end of this with Ahsoka like
she'll show up on the series for a cameo scene
another Cameo scene maybe with Sabine because they
cast her relatively early a lot of the characters
during the Ahsoka series will follow the storyline
that they set up at the end of Star Wars Rebels
so they'll be characters in live action from the
Ghost Ship for example during the Ahsoka trailer
we actually saw that Mary Elizabeth Winstead is
playing the live-action version of Hera they
didn't say when those episodes are going to
start but I'm assuming sometime during the summer
in part part of the idea is that it's set during
the Mando verse timeline like five years plus
after Return of the Jedi but I think they'll
have some flashbacks because Hayden Christensen is
supposed to Cameo as Anakin Skywalker slash Darth
Vader and we'll see some flashbacks for ahsoka's
character like there are a couple ways you include
his character and for it to make sense he can
show up as a force ghost in present day or he
can show up in flashbacks too and because there
are so many flashbacks for grogu to order 66 why
wouldn't they also have flashbacks for Live Action
Ahsoka as well at some point hopefully they'll
try a live-action version of Ahsoka versus Darth
Vader their reunion because they actually didn't
meet that many times after Order 66 because that
was their first big reunion when she fought Darth
Vader inside the Sith Temple and it was her coming
to terms with the fact that he did in fact turn
into Darth Vader I do think that they have plans
for multiple more seasons of the Mandalorian so
I don't know how they're going to end bocatan's
story with Mando they're still trying to retake
the planet Mandalore from the Empire but I believe
that's going to lead to a big conflict directly
with grand Admiral thrawn in the remnants of the
Empire moff Gideon and also a big character that
doesn't appear during the trailer he said he's
gonna have a big Renaissance during season three I
think that means that he's gonna go full Hannibal
Lecter at the first like they have him in custody
the Empire will rescue him and he'll go free
at the end of the season but the whole idea is
that thrawn is sort of like the power behind the
remnants of the empire in his Fleet moth Gideon
was sort of like the mid bad even though he seemed
like the big boss he probably thinks of himself as
the big bad they haven't said who they've cast is
thrawn yet but I think they're actually doing the
live action thing where the animated voiceover
actor Lars Mickelson just plays the live-action
version because he's a great live-action actor
and the voice would be perfect I've already talked
about where thrawn has been with Ezra Bridger
Ezra Bridger also going to be played by this
actor here and is going to be a part of the Ahsoka
series they were stuck in the unknown regions but
at some point were able to make their way back
so when the Ahsoka series begins she's looking
for Ezra Bridger and looking for thrawn they'll
probably tease where he is at the end of season
three also I think the idea that Dr Pershing
comes back in a much bigger way they'll tease
more of what the actual plot was was with them
cloning Force sensitive people trying to make
more force-sensitive troops they haven't really
addressed that in a huge way since the Mandalorian
season 2 and we haven't seen Dr purging in a while
either but it sounds like they're actually trying
to lead to a live-action version of heir to
the Empire the thrawn trilogy that was done
in the 90s which is a great Trilogy I recommend
reading those books during that some of the plot
was a little bit different Luke Skywalker was
a much bigger character and thrawn had gained
the alliance with another cloned Jedi Master who
kind of turned into a dark Jedi Master by the end
of that story so they just started dealing with
more and more Jedi clones like eventually there
was a Luke clone that Luke had to face we'll see
if there's a version of that with grogu because it
seems like grogu is a much bigger part of this
version of that adaptation of the story that
would be crazy grogu vs evil grogu I don't think
they're literally gonna do something like that
but I wouldn't be surprised and I do think that
they'll eventually bring Luke Skywalker back for
another Cameo if they're going to be doing this
heir to the Empire adaptation it almost makes you
wish they actually did the sequel Trilogy just
adapting the heir to the Empire trilogy but now
I'm kind of glad that they did it this way because
John Favreau Dave filoni can do a much better job
across a bunch of different TV series with way
more hours to adapt the story instead of trying
to cram it into six hours worth of movie there'll
be a bunch more footage because the series is
premiering in March so we'll get more trailers
really soon of course I'll do more bonus videos if
there are any big details in the trailer that you
spotted that I didn't talk about in the video or
any big questions you have just write them Below
in the comments everyone click here for my Ahsoka
trailer video in Easter eggs and clicking for my
other Pedro Pascal series The Last of Us episode
2 trailer video in Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!